alors dit moi vous en êtes avec votre
projet salut je m'appelle et me dit ce
parc je vous contacte depuis la terre tu
crois pas qu'il ya une raison qui fait
que tu aies la moins aimée de l'école
a favorisé les rêves de christopher de
communiquer avec les extraterrestres
emilie nous sommes m'agace super proche
de communiquer avec qui existe là où
imagine ce que ça va être quand on va
enfin y arriver ça va être dément
[Musique]
qu'ils nous laissent entrer
c'est arrivé dans cette ville il ya plus
de 50 ans et il n'y a eu qu'un seul
témoin
frédéric match mais monsieur qui habite
en bas de la rue sa maison est hantée
les enfants aux yeux noirs c'est la
période de leur récolte
mais pourquoi ils vous demandent s'ils
peuvent entrer ils n'ont pas le choix
ils ont besoin d'une permission et
surtout quoi qu'il arrive ne jamais dire
oui mon petit coeur la police va s'en
charger tu ne bouge plus que chez toi
mans vous comprenez pas innocente à
l'évidence du tournoi
[Musique]
tu penses obtient 10 ils vivent